all right good afternoon i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department i'm out here this afternoon
to brief you on a homicide investigation
that we are conducting in the 1400 block
of vegas valley drive which is near the
intersection of vegas valley and
maryland parkway the details that i have
right now are very plim preliminary but
at around 1 30 this afternoon metro
police responded to a report of a male
who had been shot in an apartment
directly behind me medical personnel
arrived and transported that male who is
a black male in his late 50s to sunrise
trauma where he was pronounced deceased
what we have learned is that the
deceased and a group of people were
inside of an apartment at some point
there was an argument between the
deceased and another male
in the apartment and that argument was
over the theft potential theft of a cell
phone the deceased demanded
that the other male leave the apartment
and then pulled out his handgun and
started shooting through a door toward
the
other male that other male pulled out
his own handgun and shot back striking
the deceased
the other male fled the apartment and we
are still in the process of trying to
locate them at this time i urge anybody
who has any additional information to
reach out to crime stoppers your
information is completely anonymous and
there's reward money available
through crime stoppers you can also
reach out to homicide at lvmpd.com
i'll take a couple questions if you have
them but it's still very early on in the
investigation do you have the age or the
ethnicity of the people that are
involved so the deceased is a black male
in his late 50s
the
other male involved who shot the
deceased as a black male believed to be
25 to 30 years of age
right now we're still in the process of
interviews and trying to get all that
information and it's still very early on
in the investigation so i don't have it
all i have is black the shooter is a
black male 25 to 30 and that's all we
have at this point
okay anything you'd like to tell our
community about maybe feeling safe
around in these uh
apartment complexes well this incident
involves a dispute that took place
inside of the actual apartment so with
that i appreciate you guys this time you
guys have a good afternoon okay